hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
burst balloons and this problem has
really earned that category of being a
hard
problem so this is going to be another
dynamic programming problem and
we're going to solve it with the optimal
solution which is going to be big o
of n cubed time complexity and i believe
big o of n squared memory complexity
and i'm going to try my best to explain
the intuition of this problem and kind
of walk through my thought process but
if your question
is if you saw this problem for the first
time in an interview
how would you be able to solve it that's
a good question and honestly i don't
have the answer to that unless your
interviewer
gave you a couple of hints that kind of
pointed you in the right
direction because this problem requires
a couple tricks to get it to work
efficiently
so the description is pretty simple
we're given n balloons
indexed from position zero to position n
minus one
each balloon is painted with a
particular number on it
so basically we're given an input array
of nums or other words balloons
and we're asked to burst all of the
balloons now when we burst a particular
balloon
i we are going to add to the total we're
basically going to get a total number of
coins from popping that balloon
we're going to the total that we're
going to get is basically the number
that was painted on that balloon
multiplied by the two adjacent balloons
to that balloon at that particular time
and of course we might have a balloon
that's on the boundary or on the edge of
our input array so if that's the case
for example if i minus 1 or i plus 1
are out of bounds of the input array
then we're basically going to assume
that there's
you know a couple balloons with one
painted on them on the edge
basically there's gonna be some implicit
ones so for example if this is our input
array we're assuming there's a one over
here and there's one over here the
reason why is let's say we were given an
input array of one number let's say that
value was five right if we pop this
we're going to assume that there's ones
on the edge right so if we pop five what
are we going to get we're gonna get five
times the right neighbor which is one
times the left neighbor which is one
right so basically these are just
neutral values so the total number of
coins we're going to get from a single
balloon
is just going to be that value right 5.
that makes sense that's why we're doing
this
so in this example the total number of
maximum coins we can get is 167
and that is if we first pop this one
value
and then we get three times one times
five because three and five are the
neighbors
since we pop that next what we're going
to pop is the
five now since we're popping this five
well we need to get its neighbors right
it's right neighbor is obviously
a since we popped this one its its left
neighbor now is going to be
the 3 that's over here so we're going to
do 3 times 5 times 8
so after we pop the 5 we now have 2
remaining
we're going to pop the 3 first and
that's going to give us 3
times 8 and the left neighbor of course
remember we
talked about the beginning is implied to
be a 1 so then we're going to get 1
times 3 times 8.
now the 3 has been popped last one left
is just the eight
right so the neighbors of that
implicitly are just one and one so eight
times one times one
we add that up to our total we get 167.
now
these implicit extra ones on our input
array for example
those are not actually going to be
popped right so we need to remember that
because obviously if we did pop them
right we pop a one we'd add one to our
total and if we pop the other one we'll
add another one but that's not actually
going to be the case right we don't want
to pop these extras
so even if you can't get the dynamic
programming solution at the very least
we know that there's a brute force
approach right we could choose to pop
three first we could choose to pop one
first we could choose to pop
five we could choose to pop eight right
and then we could continue
down this decision tree right that's the
brute force right
something like a backtracking approach
but in that case
obviously we have n choices roughly at
each layer
and the height of the tree is going to
be n so basically the time complexity is
going to be something like
n to the power of n now that's not super
efficient
and in this case we actually can do
better but it's not easy to
arrive to that solution so now let me
explain a little bit of the thought
process
to get us there and then i'm going to
jump into the code in this case the code
is actually not too bad once you see
the couple of tricks that we need in
this problem so we know the brute force
approach but can we identify
any sub-problems your first idea might
be something like this okay so let's say
i pop
the fifth element right we popped this
balloon now we have a new sub problem
right we have
this entire array minus this value as
the sub problem right
or for example maybe i popped one now we
would get this entire array
except the one as a sub problem right
now if i continue popping for example i
pop 1
next i pop 8 now we have a different sub
problem
so if i keep going like this how many
sub problems are we gonna have well
basically what we're doing as we pop
elements we're basically getting every
single
subsequence right now how many sub
sequences
for an input array are there well for
each value we could choose to include it
or not
include it right so for each value we
have two choices two times two
times two right we're basically going to
do this for the size of the input array
which is let's say n so we're going to
have 2 to the power of
n sub sequences so basically what i'm
getting at here
is this is not the correct sub problem
that we're looking for we need to look
for an even more
simple sub problem because if we have
this many sub problems that's not going
to help us
caching something like this is not going
to make the
the solution more efficient we want to
get something like n cubed
and squared et cetera right this is what
i'm aiming for let's try to see if we
can get it
so let's say i pop the five now is there
an even more simple sub problem well we
notice
now we actually have two subarrays right
we have one sub array over here
and one sub array over here now these
sub arrays are contiguous they're not
subsequences that's pretty good
because we know that at most for an
input array of size
n there could be at most there could be
at most
n squared sub array so that's something
we can work with to make an
efficient solution so now you might
think well can i take each of these sub
arrays right
basically by popping this we got
something like one times five
times eight now we wanna know
independently what the each of these sub
arrays
could get us like how many maximum coins
could this subreddit and this subarray
get us right independently
but what we're gonna notice is we can't
just look at this subarray independently
right because independently a three
times one right
the max we could get is we first pop the
one right
in that case we get one times three and
you know the right neighbor is nothing
so once we pop that and then we pop this
three right then we'll get
three times basically just three by
itself right so
we pop this then we add the second
balloon that we pop so we'd get a total
of six right just independently
if we had this sub subarray 3 and 1. but
we
know that in reality this 3 and 1 is now
going to be connected
to this 8 right and independently what
this 8 would get us
is 8 by itself right because it doesn't
have any neighbors so in total if we
took a
look at both of these independently we'd
get something like 6 plus 8
so in total 14 right but in reality
when we look at 3 1 8 what's the max we
could possibly get in this case
well we'd pop the 1 first right then
we'd get
three times one times eight now that's
24 that already by itself
went over the total that we would get if
we did these independently so basically
what i'm getting at is
we can't break the problem up like this
right
we can't look at these arrays separately
because in reality we know that they're
going to be connected to each other
okay so that's not going to work now
this is the part where you have to be
kind of
clever we said what happens if we pop
this one
first and then try to do the remaining
array let's reverse our
thinking instead of popping this first
let's say we pop this value last
so what happens if we pop this value
last
meaning we pop this entire subarray
and before right before we pop this and
we pop
this entire subarray before we pop this
what's going to happen then well we know
if this is the last value that we pop
meaning we popped everything here we
popped everything here its left and
right neighbors
are both going to be 1 right there's
going to be a 1 over here and there's
going to be a 1 over here so we're going
to get 1 times 5
times 1. but what's the remaining amount
that we
get from popping these two subarrays now
because in this case since we're popping
this value
last that means these two subarrays are
never going to be connected to each
other
ever not at any point because this is
being popped
last so since these two subarrays are
not going to be connected that means we
can now pop them independently so let's
take a look now let's
pop this 3-1 independently what's going
to happen
well we remember when we pop this
independently we're basically going to
get 1 times 3 plus 3 right
that's going to total up to 6 once again
right but that's not
actually what we're looking for because
remember this
sub array is not independent we are it's
true we're going to pop this before we
pop the five
but we can't just forget about the five
right there is
a five right next to this three one so
in reality when i pop the one
i'm gonna get three times one times five
and then when i pop the three because we
know we're not gonna put we're popping
this last right so we are popping these
two first
but then when i pop the three i'm gonna
get one times three
times five right because there's an
implicit one over here
so how can i handle that what i'm saying
is
our array hasn't actually changed there
the five still over here but we want to
pop all of these elements before we pop
this five how can i handle that well
it's actually not
too different than what we went over at
the beginning remember we said that
let's say we had a single element in our
input array let's say it's a three right
we're assuming even for this input array
there's gonna be an implicit
one on the left and there's going to be
an implicit one on the right
these two values are not going to be
popped when we're popping this
array but we're still assuming that
they're there for that computation that
we're going to be doing
that's exactly the same rule that we're
going to follow
so when we go from up here to down here
right
this is our sub problem so we we have we
have identified what the sub problem is
going to be it's going to be this
sub array the only thing we have to
remember is just like at the beginning
how there's going to be an
implicit 1 on the left now there's going
to be an
implicit 5 on the right so
for the sub array that we're doing the
left boundary
is going to be at this value the right
boundary is going to be
at this value but these values are not
going to go away
we are going to leave this in the input
array and
we are going to make sure that we have
an implicit 1 at the beginning of the
input array
and similarly when we want to solve this
subarray we are going to assume that
yeah there's just a single eight right
so the left boundary is going to be here
as well as the right boundary both
boundaries are going to be here but
we're going to assume that there's an
implicit 1 at the right
and this 5 is not going away the 5 is
going to be here as well we're not going
to pop it because take a look at our
boundary our boundary tells us just to
pop
this subarray before we end up doing
anything else so this is going to stay
here we're not going to pop it
but it is going to contribute to the
total number of coins for example when
we pop eight
we're gonna get five times eight times
one that's going to be the total number
of coins we get
once we pop this entire sub-array so
using
sub-arrays using this technique where
for every value we're going to identify
well what if we popped this value
last that allows us to actually get a
sub problem that we can cache now in our
cache it's going to be
let's say we call it dp this is our
cache it's going to be a two dimensional
cache because we are going to be using
the left value as the first index and
the right value as the
second index these left and right values
are basically just going to tell us
what the sub array is from the original
array right left is going to be the left
boundary
r is going to be the right boundary with
that being said let me just give you a
quick
high level run through of the algorithm
and then we're going to dive into the
code
so we remember in the brute force we
started out with okay what happens if we
pop this first what happens if we pop
this
first right so that's going to give us a
decision tree now we're going to do it a
little bit differently our decision tree
now is going to be what happens if we
pop
this last what happens if we pop this
last
what happens if we pop this last which
one of those paths
is going to lead us to the maximum
number of coins right
so we are still going to brute force it
kind of we are going to have that exact
same decision tree
only thing is we're going to use a cache
we're going to take that sub problem and
cache them so for example let's say we
pop this value last what am i going to
do
and we actually are going to modify the
input array so we are gonna add that
implicit one at the beginning and at the
end
but our boundary is gonna be left is
gonna be from here and right is gonna be
from here that's ultimately
these are the values that we're actually
gonna be popping we're not actually
gonna be popping these
again the brute force what happens if we
pop this last
if we pop this last our left subarray
becomes
empty right there's nothing there in the
left sub-array
but our right sub-array is going to have
this entire portion right
so since currently our boundary our left
boundaries here in our right boundaries
here if we pop
this value last this is what our total
is gonna be we're gonna get
so if we pop this last we know it's
gonna
we're gonna end up popping everything
here before that right so when we pop
this value we're gonna get
three times one times one right so what
i'm gonna say is three
times nums of right which is over here
plus
one and nums of left which is over here
minus one that's going to give us once
we pop this
plus we want the remaining number of
coins that we get
from popping the remaining portion of
the left sub array we see that there's
nothing here right
remember we're not actually popping this
value there's no other values in between
so there is no left sub array what about
the right sub array we're going to take
our left pointer shift it by
one that's going to put left over here
so the right sub array is going to be
all of these elements right so you can
see we're going to get that total amount
computed from our dp
right we're going to get it from our dp
if that's already been computed as a sub
problem if it hasn't been computed then
we're just going to do that
brute force depth first search passing
in these same parameters right
l plus one and right now let's look at
it for a more general
case if we were popping let's say a
middle value as the last value where we
actually do have both a left sub array
and a right sub array what's the
equation going to look like then
so we were looking at if we popped this
value last next we're going to look at
if we pop this value
last we're also then going to look at
this and this right that's basically the
brute force right so basically we're
going to have an i right it's going to
start here
it's going to run all the way through
the end of the input array but now if we
pop
this last we know that if if this was
popped last we'd end up popping all of
this first and we'd pop this first so
then once we popped this its left would
be the one
its right would be the one right so
that's where we're getting this from
right
r plus one's here left minus one is over
here
multiplied by the value at index i which
is one right
but then what's our right sub array
going to be clearly this is what the
right sub array remaining sub array is
right how much could we get from
doing that well again in our dp or if
it's not already computed in our dp
we're basically going to call our depth
search clearly you can see that the left
boundary now is i
plus one right basically we're taking
this i moving it over here our right
boundary remains
unchanged right this is the sub array
that's what i'm saying here
what about our left sub array over here
well the left boundary didn't change
but the right boundary was decremented
by one that makes sense right
so that's basically the idea now my
question is we know why the memory
complexity is big o of n squared right
the
cache is basically going to be from
every single subarray right
and it's two dimensional so that makes
sense i think why it's
the memory is n squared but why is the
time complexity big o
n cubed well we know we're going to be
breaking this problem down
into sub problems of every single
subarray we know that there's
n squared number of sub arrays right so
for once we have a sub array right like
let's consider the entire input array
was a sub array right
we know that for every subway we're
basically going to be iterating through
every value right this is the first this
is the second this is the
and so on and so on right and
considering if this was the last value
popped so
it's basically taking the total number
of sub arrays which we know is n squared
and multiplying it by another n because
we're having to iterate through every
single
value for a given subarray with that
being said let's jump into the code once
you actually know these tricks and
especially once you know
this formula the algorithm is actually
pretty easy with
recursion so like i mentioned we are
going to be
updating the input array we're basically
going to be adding a 1 at the beginning
and then adding a 1 at the end we're
also going to be having
a cache i'm going to call it dp because
it's short and then we can start with
our
depth first search function so let's
define it we know that we're just going
to have left
and right boundaries right so basically
left and right are going to be indices
of the input array but let's call that
depth first search function we know
we're just going to be end up calling it
and then returning the results so let's
do that before we actually define the
function
now what am i going to pass in as a left
and right boundary zero
and you know the last index no right
because we don't want to actually
include
this one and we don't want to include
this one so i'm going to be passing in
zero plus one which is one and basically
passing in
the length of the entire empire numbs
minus two because we know
this minus one would give us the last
value minus 2 is going to be 1
less than that so because remember we're
not actually popping these
and these okay so now what are actually
the base cases for this algorithm well
if left equaled right that means we have
only one
balloon left to pop so that's actually
okay but if left
past the right pointer so if left became
greater than right
that's when we know we've ran out and
that's when we know we're gonna
we're gonna return zero meaning there's
nothing left to pop
otherwise maybe we've already computed
this before and it's already in our
cache
right this left and right pair is
already in dp in that case we're just
going to return dp
of left and right otherwise
we know that it hasn't been computed so
now it's our time to actually compute it
so let's set it initially to zero
and now we're going to determine what is
the max number of coins we could get
for this pair so remember we're going to
be iterating through every i
considering if at index i that balloon
was the last balloon we popped so let's
go through every index from
left all the way to right and let's
compute the number of coins
we could get from that so we know that
if
this numbs of i was popped last we'd get
numbs
of i multiplied by nums
of right plus 1 multiplied
numbs of left minus one right and now to
coins we're going to
add the additional coins that we would
get from the left and right
sub arrays right so we're going to be
calling our depth first search function
the left boundary stays the same and
we're gonna do i
minus one and we're also going to be
calling it for the right subarray which
we know we can get
with i plus one as a left boundary and
our right boundary is going to stay the
same so now we've computed the total
number of coins right it makes sense why
we're doing this
and then calling our debt for search
function so now we can potentially
update the result which we know we're
storing here in dp
of left and right so we're going to
update it to the max of potentially what
it already
is and the max of what we just computed
the total number of coins that we just
computed and so we're basically going to
be running through the entire loop
doing that i hope that this kind of
makes it a little more obvious of why
this is n cubed we know that this debt
for search function
the maximum possible number of ways it
could be called is
n squared right every pair of the left
and right indices could be n squared
times
e and then if we actually if it's
already been cached then we're going to
return it in big o
of one time if it hasn't been cached
meaning it's the first time we're
computing this
we're going to have to run through a
linear time loop
and for each of these pairs we are going
to have to run through a loop at least
once so that's what's going to give us
the n cubed
time complexity but yeah once this has
been computed we know
you know we can just go ahead and return
it from this recursive function
and that is the entire thing so
you know we defined a function inside of
a function but once you know
you know the trick which is not so
obvious we do have to do this
and then we do have that relationship of
you know we're popping this
this balloon last it's not super
intuitive but once you do have it
hopefully your interviewer gives you
that hint
but and if you do get that the code is
actually not too bad as you can see when
you do
recursion so i hope that this was
helpful if it was
please like and subscribe it supports
the channel a lot and i'll hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching